[Music]
hi I'm Simone de LaRue creator of body
by Simone I decided I wanted to hang up
my dancing heels and segue into fitness
I wanted to bring the love of dance and
the creativity and the freedom and the
joy to as many women as possible so
obviously I trained a lot of celebrities
Jennifer Garner is one of my favorites
that I've been with for four years now
honestly one of the nicest people I have
ever met probably one of the only women
I will get up at 5:00 a.m. every morning
to go and train her for especially when
she was training for her film peppermint
obviously Chrissy Teigen I dream it for
three or four years we do more laughing
than working out to be honest she's Anna
larious person and I liked having a
giggle with her sticking to a workout
plan is tough yeah we always start off
strong we're out the gate really strong
and then we kind of dwindle down when we
realize oh my goodness this is actually
hard work my advice is there is no quick
fix oh yes it is hard work so one thing
you can do is keep an exercise journal
you can have a workout buddy to keep you
accountable if you know you have to be
there and see that workout buddy at 7:00
a.m. and not let them down that's really
going to help motivate you as well and I
always say to every client choose a goal
whether that's the Oscars whether that's
a red carpet whether that's a movie role
whatever that goal is for you set it so
then you've got something to work
towards and that will keep you
accountable and that will also keep you
motivated for me the driving force is
music that's what really motivates me
and that's what motivates you in dance
because obviously you're working to a
rhythm to timing to an 8-count
so like crank on some tunes I always say
to a client picked up a playlist
whatever music you love and that will be
different for everybody but whatever
mode of a
so you put those tunes on because
immediately it's going to put you in a
good mood and it's gonna motivate you
some of the mistakes that people make
when working out is to actually not
research how to do the exercise
correctly I'll often walk into a gym and
see people using heavy weights lifting
heavy weights using machinery that they
they haven't done any research for so
I'd always say if you can at least get a
personal trainer at least once to teach
you how to use the machines and teach
you and give you a program because you
need to use correct technique and
correct form you could do the exercise
for a hundred reps and not use correct
technique and form and end up injuring
yourself and you're not actually going
to see any change in your body for me
health and wellness is not just a quick
fix
it's not the latest fad or the latest
workout it is a lifestyle choice and a
lifestyle change it's not just oh I've
got to work out I'm gonna try and wiener
push through for an hour every day and
then you know change my diet immediately
that's setting yourself up for failure
my philosophy is yes you can have a good
time yes you can have wine every now and
then but we want to balance that with
you know good eating good exercise and a
good mindset meditation and sleep will
set you up for a perfect life
[Music]